gerade leute als ich dachte es keine
nicht mehr selbst aber werden ihre mache
ich ein neues video auf zwei schlecht
ist der kanal weltweit der letzten 30
tage und kein scheiß ich kann zusätzlich
zeigen aber es liegt einfach straighten
der frau nackt vor der kamera selbst
geht somit kommen eben jahr 2018 leute
selbstverständlich habe ich den
gestrigen abend den 31.12 so verbrachte
dass ich keinesfalls jetzt gerade mega
fertig bin oder so das kann ich
definitiv schon mal aufschließen oder
dem wir das geklärt haben leute kann
heute natürlich wieder ein video kommt
es gibt so eine seite die kennt ihr
vielleicht auch schon die wird meistens
sehr viel verwendet dass man nach guckt
wie viele aufrufe und youtube einen
gewissen monat macht oder wie viele
abonnenten der youtuber macht oder wie
viel geld der vielleicht so grob
verdient mit youtube mit ungewissen
monat und diese details zu spät die
bieter der beratende funktion neben
nachgucken wieviel kohle macht julia und
wie viele abonnenten macht und zwar die
möglichkeiten sich die schlechtesten
youtube weltweit an zuschauer das sind
heute macht ein top ten schlechtest
youtuber weltweit in den letzten 30
tagen wir schauen die alle befinden aus
ist die gemacht haben und ich gebe und
dann tipps die ihr persönlich für einen
youtube kanal auch umsetzen könnte damit
ihr auch dann unter die schlechteste
note über den beiden kommt super fange
an leute auch was 10 befindet sich der
kanal sky moon der hat in den letzten 30
tagen sage und schreibe 35 tausend
abonnenten verloren also schlechter
kanal heißt der kanal die meisten
abonnenten verloren hatten und wir
schauen uns einfach mal was der gute auf
seinem kanal so macht muss jetzt
ziemlich beschissen sein
das ist schon ein bisschen speziell der
kanal ist kein wunder so von den
fantasievollen videos sind könnte man
sagen okay kinderkanal halten aber achte
meistertitel sind einfach arabisch
der kanal ist sky und englisch ja auf
den bildern sind weiße kinder und die
titel separates ach du scheiße
moment moment könnte ich auch mal um die
ecke
ich vergesse dass gerade noch mal alles
gab es ist russisch also okay aber das
gerne so auflösen sollte falls irgendwo
muss er findet das klappt ihr einfach
machten kanal mit so richtig seltsam
videos und keiner spricht und dem
arabische titel dann kommt ihr in den
top ten des schlechtesten kanäle platz
neun ist niemand geringeres als der
kanal hat sage und schreibe 45.000
abonnenten verlobt und den letzten 30
tagen alles gerade ja es ist ein
microsoft kanal ok japanische minecraft
auf jeden fall muss ich definitiv
zustimmen wir recht steil waren channel
country
dann deutet alles zurück macht keine
japanischen markt können ihr macht teil
dieses manko skandiert comics bis acht
heute belegt von somali new
entertainment 45.600 630 abonnenten
verloren die letzten 30 tagen er hat
sich bewusst dazu
was das auch gehört gebe ich mal dieses
banner ehrungen da steht also leicht
versteckt als heute das nur paar leute
lesen best channel deutet das ist der
beste kanal
hier ist aber die offizielle bestätigung
es ist hat sich der bestseller und der
beste frau weltweit ist so maly
entertainment mit sogar einen videos wie
samt sei scharf
carlo janka 3 alles klar geht um
beschissen mache weiter leute platz
sieben unterschiedlichen kanäle werden
weil sie ist so oma in die an ein pater
sage und schreibe 53 1653 abonnenten in
letzten teils klar verloren also auch
wenn ziemlich beschissene hatte frank
alter 78 millionen abonnenten der kanal
wird scheinbar von 24 jährigen hier um
geführt wir machen wie es wie die ader
claims princess diana player des corsa
flowers ja place wird toll findet übels
oh mein gott
roma indianer im play-off balloons 91
millionen aufrufe menschenrechte sind
ziemlich abstoßend ich sage euch doch
was leute ich finde solche kanäle so
creepy auf den so kleine kinder sind
weil die garantiert natürlich von den
eltern gemacht werden und ich weiss ich
finde das ultra coriso kinder kanäle
geschäfte ohne bezahlen die kommentare
was ihr davon haltet weil ich kann das
gar nicht ab
das war sehr traumatisiert heute machen
wir mit platz sechs das ist disco show
der hat 56.000 sie mit 650 aber dem
verloren hier ist man doch diesen kanal
gehört erhalten was allein schon diese
typen so nach dem motto egal was du
machst die ganze familie
diese plattform so ziehen beim militär
zunächst professionell zu wirken im
hintergrund etwas unruhig auf 81 screens
selber durch nicht wild ich kann
irgendwo schon bestehen doch mal diese
karte der abonniert wollte jeden der
einzelne bisher ist einfach fucking
seltsam what the [ __ ] 55 heute legen ich
habe auch gar nicht so viele daten vor
dass es geht und transit videoguard 77
tausend abonnenten verloren sie das 1400
achtung herr zu sein und man konnte das
gefühl richtig setzen auch ok ich habe
es gerade bei transit video versucht es
gibt ein kanal auf youtube den tanz
video heißt das ist der ihr dabei keine
videos keine pläne eine playlist live
music house schaut euch mal dieses war
sitzt als alte welche ecken vom internet
hab ich mich gerade begeben ok bleibt
risiko aus dem 12
ohne witz ich komm nicht klar
platz vier leute es geht weiter ist dann
natürlich schon john church mit 84 1860
abonnenten verloren letzten rest an
leute an dieser stelle profi tipp wenn
ihr selbst ein kleiner aufmachen wollte
und auch gerne eine million abonnenten
wie diese junge dame hier erreichen
wollt macht einfach es folgendes machen
japanischen kanal oder taiwanesische
teilplan irgendwo sind dann setzt sich
einfach euer zimmer reinschauen nicht
die kamera und flüstert irgendwas
feuchten was auch einfach das können
einfach so stur sein wie man kann also
schwarze magie oder so sie beschwert da
irgendeinen dämonen oder so ich würde
ich könnte dich wissen platz drei leute
scheinbar geht es ist eine ganz andere
ecke der welt und zwar von a sind nach
brasilien mit multi die vulgaris 211.000
abonnenten verloren letzten 30 tagen
es wird wirklich nicht besser wird es
wird wirklich nicht besser die kanäle
werden nicht wirklich weniger seltsam
wir wieder ein banner was komplett
selbst dann ist es immer abgeschnitten
am rand und es sieht aus auf den ersten
blick leute als wäre das ein skandal für
brasilianisches schlagermusik perfekt
genau da will ich hin
muss ich wirklich schon gehört wenn
meine reaktion die ganze wiese ungefähr
gleichen gesichtsausdruck ist sowie
einfach so hin zu klobig und diese netze
weil ich einfach keine ahnung ich wusste
nicht dass es so was im internet gibt
leute es schaut mich jetzt einfach platz
zwei der schlechtesten kann element bald
deutlich ist karachi motoren die guter
zwei der 35.000 abonnenten verloren
oh mein gott oh gott das wird glaube ich
noch rot sah also ist als ich dachte
jetzt keinen nicht mehr selbst aber
werden hier mache ich ein neues video
auf zwei schlecht ist der kanal weltweit
der letzten 30 tage und kein scheiß ich
kann zusätzlich zeigen aber es liegt
einfach straighten der frau nackt vor
der kamera
und irgendwie anders formel annäherung
an das video heiße partys waxing for
educational purposes only werden sollte
stellte dieses video zu sehen so viele
abgefüllte scheiße witz und ich hab
jetzt schon heute sehen wir hier ist ein
youtube-video dürfen wie youtube ist
eine saubere plattform ein grund gilt
dieses video jahr und es liegt einfach
ein nackter mensch dann ab so richtig
denn normalerweise eher weniger da wo
wir noch nie im kanal alles ganz amerika
laufen statt leute sind genau 3 videos
auf ihrem kanal und alle drei drehen
sich um entfernung von schwaben
wieso die abonniert man so einen kanal
kann ich jetzt eine stelle nicht
verstehen aber jetzt sollte ich bin
vorbereitet ich habe wirklich alles
gesehen was von dem internet auf youtube
posten kann ich kann jetzt nichts mehr
schaffen aber ich habe trotzdem ein
gutes gefühl man die nummer eins
anschauen
fanta kitzingen 452.000 abonnenten
letzten 30 tage verloren und ich will
eigentlich nicht sehen warum aber
irgendeiner musste machen
das ist einfach nicht mehr normal was
ist dass leute zwar eingeschaltet habe
ich gedacht habe so ja ob ich guck mal
wie oft es geht an der macht wieder ist
und das ist lustig aber ich bin ja
gerade einfach nur geschockt es ist
irgendwie animiert fünf kühen fallen in
fünf stellen
dann öffnet sich der eine und dann
fliegen der zehn rote eis am stiel in
den mund und auf einmal wird die crew
selbst drohte 60.000 dollar monatlicher
umsatz
mein gott was mache ich falsch in meinem
leben
die feier gestern abend dann setze mich
heute denke ich mache ein schönes die
hierher kommen zu lassen
ich komme wirklich mal klar leute ich
bin schwer geschockt hat ihr könnt ihr
eine folge was das geht weg von meinem
projekt mit unitymedia und jemand klar
abonnieren peter führst du schon soweit
und ich hoffe ihr wisst zu schätzen dass
ich einfach meine gesundheit ist
aufgefordert für dieses video
aber okay